several countries have offered to help
Morocco with relief efforts so far the
Moroccan government has only accepted
offers from four nations they are Qatar
Spain the United Arab Emirates and the
UK and they've all begun deliveries of
AIDS let's go live to Natasha Butler now
who's in Paris France voice France
Natasha has also offered to help
that's right the French President
Emmanuel macron is devastated by what
has happened in Morocco says that rescue
teams are on standby same message from
the French Foreign Ministry they say
they are just waiting for the green
light from Morocco but that has yet to
come no word from Morocco and whether or
not they're going to accept this aid
from France now French officials here
are trying to downplay that they are
saying that Morocco is obviously
overwhelmed and is looking at his
Logistics and for now perhaps it has no
need for this help from France but
others are saying this is probably
likely due to the fact that relations
between Morocco and France have been
particularly strained in recent years
over a number of issues France for
example has refused to recognize the
territory of the western Sahara as
Moroccan it has tightened visa rules for
some Moroccans and we're about unhappy
about paris's raposh more growing
closeness to Algeria so those are some
of the reasons for uh tensions over the
past few years also a strange
relationship between the Moroccan King
and president Emmanuel macro and that is
why some believe that this offer evade
from France has yet to be accepted and
there's a big Moroccan community in
France a huge diaspora there and have
been deeply deeply affected by by this
crisis back home how are they responding
a huge Moroccan Community because of the
historic ties between uh France and
Morocco about 1 billion 600 Moroccan
some of them dual Nationals of course
French uh Moroccan and they have been
deeply affected as you say they are
upset they are wondering whether or not
their family and their friends are okay
people are still unable to contact many
many relatives and friends we know that
some local charities here and mosques
have been mobilizing to try and get Aid
to Morocco and there's also a sense of
anger over the fact that rabbat has not
accepted this offer of crucial aid from
France because every minute of course
counts on the ground there and people
say look when it comes to saving lives
surely the politics have to be put aside
Natasha thank you for that Natasha
Butler live there in Paris well let's
speak to Mr Abdel Malik alawi about this
he's president of the Moroccan Institute
for strategic intelligence and is
joining us from the capital robot thank
you very much Mr alawi for being with us
on Al Jazeera so so far as we've said
Morocco has only officially accepted aid
from four countries Spain the UK the
euae and Qatar can you help us
understand first how the authorities
decide which foreign aid to accept based
on what
hi good morning thanks for having me
um this question of uh how to channel
International Aid is at the center of
the conversation since day one and since
the moment that Morocco had this
catastrophe but we have a curve of
experience in Morocco that if you get
too much Aid at the same time
unorganized you will have bottlenecks
all over the place and this will be very
complicated to handle
and the second thing is that we've seen
a lot of questions about geopolitics and
relationships but Morocco clarified very
clearly yesterday night through a press
release from the minister of interior
that all all International Aid is
welcome in Morocco but it has to be
organized and it has to come in a proper
way so you don't create these
bottlenecks and your reporter on the
ground stated how complicated and
difficult it is because you only have
one road you have a very long column now
of logistics trying to get there you
want to make sure that this Aid is not
adding a problem to a problem but of
course this is a terrible catastrophe
you have a lot of frustration you have a
lot of anger you have a lot of
self-proclaimed Specialists that are
trying to put their their say in what's
happening in Morocco and everybody
improvise himself as a logistician or
specialist in humanitarian Aid right
this complicates the the issue right now
but when you when when you said that
four countries were accepted Spain is
the closest one to Morocco it's only 12
miles north of Morocco so it was easier
to get uh
UK and not France for example
well it depends on the shopping list of
the Moroccan government and what they
want to bring in at this moment there is
very specific expertise depending on
countries and in Morocco this is a a
region with mountains and there are
specific needs when it comes to France
it's a controversy that is mainly a
French controversy everybody's speaking
about it but in Morocco nobody's talking
about this because uh people are very
much focused on rescuing the people on
the ground and trying to overcome this
issue of logistics right but it's normal
but do you understand though that the
frustration of Moroccans who live in
France who think that the French
government could be helping right now
the large Moroccan community that lives
in France
well actually I understand all
frustrations and I understand
frustrations from Moroccans from
Moroccan living abroad this is totally
normal when you have an event of this
magnitude because people want to act and
want and are sometimes desperate to find
ways to act but I can tell you there are
no geopolitics Morocco is pragmatic in
its way that it deals with other
countries but I have to remind you of
something uh superpowers don't have
convictions they have agendas and they
have vested interests Morocco is working
to promote its best and vital interest
in order to organize the rescue
operations right now right you know when
you look at the humanitarian response to
the earthquake in Turkey earlier this
year for example it was really massive
various countries and international
organizations responded 105 countries 16
International organizations sent in
humanitarian Aid 11 countries including
Israel including Greece provided teams
with you know search and rescue dogs to
find victims under the rubble there of
course we it is too early to compare the
scale of the disasters the two disasters
but it's you know difficult to
comprehend perhaps why Morocco is not
accepting more International Help which
could be coordinated by the United
Nations as it was a case in Turkey
I think the wording is very important I
do understand that TV channels need to
do audience and they want to compare the
situation in turkey with the situation
in Morocco in Turkey it was in urban
area it was a disaster that was terrible
but it was hurting an urban area and it
needed some kind of response in Morocco
it's in a rural and mountainous area for
which the situation is very very very
different in the way you will organize
International Aid and how you will
Channel it and of course as I told you a
lot of people are are speaking about how
Morocco can do things better and can
accept but I have to say something about
wording Morocco did not refuse
International Aid it is trying to
channel it in the best way to serve the
best interests of the population and
it's not refusing these are words that
came out in the media that are
completely wrong and you can ask any
Specialist of this kind of catastrophe
The First 48 hours are indeed very
crucial to try to rescue lives and at
the same time it's the only time where
you can have the exact
shopping list of what you need in terms
of international Aid so of course there
are controversies it always happens when
you have catastrophes like this but you
cannot compare the situation of Morocco
with the situation of turkey these are
two different things okay thank you so
much for talking to us Mr Abdul Malik
alawi president of the Moroccan
Institute for strategic intelligence and
we're just getting new numbers from the
interior Ministry in Morocco which says
now at
2497 people have been killed in this
earthquake in Morocco the death toll
Rising there let's speak now to David
whitwick Who's chief executive of the UK
Med of UK Med which is a medical charity
that has just arrived in Morocco is
joining us from London thank you very
much for speaking to us so your team has
just arrived Morocco what is their
initial assessment of the situation what
are they going to be focusing on
yeah so the most important thing for the
team at the moment is to liaise as
closely as possible with the Moroccan
government and local authorities and to
get up to the most affected area in
order to have an idea of the the extent
and the scale of the needs so I know
that they've met already with uh
representatives of the Moroccan
government and we we already had someone
there a couple of days ago
um working with the British Embassy as
well
you know on the ground when you arrive
on the ground when the teams arrive you
know they they have to make an
assessment of the facilities on the
ground and what there is of course is do
the facilities there and and expertise
is there expertise and the equipment
needed to deal with the types of
injuries that were sustained by by
victims of this earthquake
yeah so all of these the earthquakes
break down in terms of scale and
complexity and I think the challenge
with this one is complexity so it's the
fact that the area that is worst
affected is remote is rural
um the infrastructure probably wasn't
terribly good prior to the earthquake so
I don't know that there's necessarily a
shortage of supplies and equipment in
the whole of Morocco but getting it
where it's most needed in the right time
is the real challenge yeah David I don't
know if you heard our previous guests
who were saying that we we cannot
compare this earthquake in Morocco with
that in Turkey yet because of course we
don't know the scale of it and in Turkey
it was an urban area in Morocco you're
dealing with more mountainous areas I
know your teams responded to the
earthquakes in Turkey
um in in you know in terms of uh the
response how is it organized in this
situation you know foreign teams like
yours when they come come into the
country how do you work in tandem with
local authorities
so it's quite an established structure
and the the way things are coordinated
is through
um a un team so United Nations and the
different United Nations agencies that
work with the rest of us so we work with
who World Health Organization
um and what happens whether the uh the
emergencies are large or or small it's
the same process when we enter the
country we contact the local authorities
and we talk to the United Nations the
United Nations then coordinate the
international effort with and on behalf
of
um the local government
yeah we're looking at the latest
pictures that we're getting uh from some
of the areas affected David and
emergency crews they're focusing of
course their efforts on these remote
mountainous villages
do you think there's hope of finding
more people alive nearly 72 hours after
this earthquake struck
well in Turkey in Turkey the search and
rescue were managing to pull people out
of the rubble over a week after but it
was colder which means people probably
had a better chance of survival but I
mean it's difficult for me to to comment
on the specific circumstances uh in
individual villages in Morocco at this
point but certainly people have survived
for far longer than a couple of days
thank you very much David for talking to
us thank you for your time David wet
week from the UK metamedical charity
that has just arrived in Morocco to help
with the search and rescue efforts there
thank you for your time